does it hit you at all do you allow it
to penetrate your mind at all that this
very well could be your last home game
as a patron alright I haven't thought
about those things and you know this I
wouldn't be thinking about those things
anyway you know it's it's been felt like
a normal week for me so I just post
practice like I always have and try to
do the best I could do
Tom Randi talking about the possibility
that will be his last home game with the
Patriots could be his last game ever
with the Patriots if they lose to the
Titans on Saturday night and Tom Brady's
not thinking about any of that look
cyborgs don't entertain human emotion
big Kenton I've been saying all week the
Patriots are the Terminator assume that
they are dead at your own peril turn
your back on that puddle of goo and up
comes the Terminator to slice you in
half that's who the Patriots are we've
seen it time and again they want us to
say it's over they want us to say Tom
Brady's leaving they want us to say all
the negative things because they use
that as their fuel to prove to everyone
there's still the Patriots yeah this
game is interesting to me because of
what you just said and I have a rule
where if I pick a game I want to be
right obviously I want to be right but
more than that I don't want to be
embarrassed I don't want to sit on my
couch on Saturday night watch the
Patriots go up 14 nothing and say to
myself you did it again you dum-dum you
bet on Ryan Tannehill going into Fox
that's if the Titans keep this close I
don't think it would shock anyone
because the Titans are a good team
they've played great football Ryan
Tannehill has been the best quarterback
in the NFL since he took over it's crazy
to say that but it's the truth
his numbers have been eye popping the
they score points at you know up and
down the field with Ryan Tannehill as
their quarterback but when it comes to
and I know this is I think you had this
disagreement with Sims earlier this week
you know betting on mystique betting on
on a team that's done it before
I don't care Tom Brady Bill Belichick in
January in Foxborough against a
quarterback making his first playoff
start in his career come on that's
crazy that is crazy so I also Mike I
want to go back real quick two weeks ago
I know last week was it was was baffling
because more than the Patriots losing
the Dolphins it was a Bill Belichick
team that didn't feel like they were
ready you know what I mean they came out
kind of flat and their defense didn't
perform the level to the level that did
all the rest of the year they kind of
thought we'll just come out here we'll
roll the helmets out and we'll beat the
Dolphins that was the weird part to me
it wasn't that the Patriots somehow got
exposed to the point where their
problems are so huge we know what their
problems are their offense is not
dynamic and their defense can be run on
at times but more than anything it was a
lack of you know maybe not preparation
but feeling like that was a game they
had to win so throw that out though what
happened two weeks ago when Tom Brady
threw back the clock and had an all-time
performance against the Buffalo Bills
are we just forgetting that I know that
it's very quick to to throw throw the
Patriots out and I'm not saying they're
a Super Bowl team I think they're gonna
lose next week to the Kansas City Chiefs
what I'm saying is if you're talking
about Tom Brady and Bill Belichick in
Foxborough in January I'm not going
against that yeah it is gonna be a lot
harder to have faith in the Patriots
next week but I agree with you
everything that we've seen for the last
20 years counts for something
41 playoff starts for Tom Brady when we
include tomorrow night's game he's got
30 postseason wins big cat which is more
than the 11 starting quarterbacks in
this year's field combined that's the
kind of love and look it's two full
seasons plus of playoff football he
knows what it's like to operate with
your season on the line he's done it
time and time and time again and here's
Ryan Tannehill for the first time ever
in the eighth year of his career for the
first time ever he's starting a playoff
game and you know Simms believes it's
more embarrassing to not realize that
it's staring us right in the face that
the Titans are the better team but then
I think I disagree and it sounds like
you do too it would be far more
embarrassing to discount all the success
all the greatness all the achievements
we've seen from a team that that has won
playoff games in the past where they
were written off
where we did think they weren't the
better team and they still found a way
to get it done dating all the way back
to Super Bowl 36 when they somehow beat
the Rams yeah I'm not saying this is
gonna be a blowout and I'm not saying
the Titans don't deserve to be there and
I don't think that you know the Titans
have been a very very good team in the
last two months and Derrick Henry has
been a force of nature we talked about
you know Derrick Henry tractor seto is
his nickname when we get to November in
December
guys don't want to tackle him anymore
and the number said he has put up in the
last two months of the season the last
three years have been absolutely eye
popping so when you have a guy like that
you can run the football
you can hopefully control a little clock
keep the ball out of Tom Brady's hands I
think that will obviously play a huge
part in the Titans having success I'm
just simply going off the fact that it's
Tom Brady and Bill Belichick in January
if that makes me stupid that's fine
there's it's just I don't think the
Patriots are that good this year but I
also know that they have the ability to
still be the Patriots when they need to
throw back the clock like Tom Brady did
against the Buffalo Bills and everyone
said that was a vintage Tom Brady
performance that was two weeks ago that
wasn't that wasn't three years ago that
was two weeks ago so yeah they look bad
against the Dolphins and that was a head
scratcher and that actually again more
confirms what they already knew the
Patriots are not a Super Bowl team this
year but it doesn't confirm the fact
that they can't win a game in January at
home against the Tennessee Titans and I
agree with you if I'm gonna be wrong I'm
gonna be wrong by believing in two
decades of greatness I'll believe in
that
the Titans still have a lot to prove to
me and they may be the better team and
they may win the game in Ryan Tannehill
may play like the guy who posted the
fourth-highest full season passer rating
that we've ever seen one 17.5 he started
10 games but still that's a hell of an
achievement and Derrick Henry has been
great and he's playing for a contract
right or the franchise tag I mean the
Titans gonna have some big decisions to
make they have two key players in Ryan
Tannehill and Derrick Henry who are due
to become free agents in March so you
know they have a team that has
individuals who are motivated
financially to go out there and have a
big game and the team is motivated to
show what it can do and oh by the way
there is snow possibly in the forecast
for this one they're calling it winter
storm Henry I
hate that they named winter storms but
they do winter storm Henry will that
matter to Derek Henry will that I mean
it's at that plays into the pet plays
into the Patriots mystique right we wait
the winter storms actually named Henry
it's named Henry and now I'm betting on
the Titans you're not everything I said
just throw it out there's a winter storm
Henry coming to New England when Derek
Henry is also going to play the I'm yeah
it's changed everything I said flip it
all everything I said play it back for
your for if you if you have a DVR play
it back and then just pretend I said the
exact opposite there's a would Henry
coming to New England and Derek Henry's
playing come on it's also his birthday
tomorrow
does that does that reinforce your voice
that plays into it yes this all plays
into it so I'm gonna have 250 it is
amazing it is amazing how well he plays
and remember the last we ever saw of
Darrelle Revis two years ago was making
a business decision to not try to tackle
Derek Henry on what ultimately became a
third down conversion that allowed the
Titans to ice the clock in Kansas City
against the Chiefs I mean who wants to
get in this guy's way they asked Bill
Belichick earlier this week how you go
about simulating Derek Henry in practice
and he said it's impossible
being the combination of size speed and
power it's amazing he is not the most
well known running back in the NFL or at
least one of the guy we'd never talked
about Derek Henry is it because he plays
for the Titans and nobody cares about
the Titans isn't that odd and if you're
Mike Vrabel but you find a way to you
hey this is our way to take all those
people out there that think we're just
just you know some bottom-of-the-barrel
team that is the Washington Generals so
the Harlem Globetrotters this is our
chance to prove to everyone that we that
we are a part of this landscape and
we've got some great players yeah
absolutely I think the to answer your
question about why we don't talk about
Derek Henry as much as maybe some of the
other quarterback or running backs in
the NFL is that he doesn't catch the
ball enough I the running back position
in the NFL has become a spot where look
at Christian McCaffrey over a hundred
yards 100 catches this year guys who are
talked
about at that extra level that elite
level and I'm I Derrick Henry is elite
by the way they catch the ball as well
and their dynamic and though in both
ways and and they can burn you both ways
so I'd say that's probably the only
reason I'm just trying to find a reason
why we don't talk about them and that's
probably a decent reason but we should
still talk about him more than we do
because he has been phenomenal in those
numbers go back and look at those
numbers
I'm telling you November December the
last three years he has been insane
insane no one wants to tackle this guy
no one can tackle this guy he is an
incredible running back in the old
school fashion Mike and I think maybe
that plays into it too he can just beat
guys up he doesn't have the Christian
McCaffrey the the wow factor that some
of these newer running backs have but he
could do it and he can do it in January
he can do it in December and he can do
it when there's weather storm Henry
coming to Foxborough on Saturday he had
one 100-yard rushing game before
November the 10th and it was exactly 100
yards it was exactly 100 yards September
29 at Atlanta since November 10 188 159
149 103 86 they sat him for the Saints
game he was kind of injured but he could
have played if that game mattered and
then 211 to end the season in the game
they had to have to get to the playoffs
and Mike I'm not I'm not a bad pick Mike
that's it though we've we've been
talking about it on pardon my take since
since November December started this is
that when Derrick Henry season starts
it's a different type of you know beast
that you're working with here last year
they had that game against Jax when he
ran for 238 yards had four touchdowns
that happened in December like he gets
to this part of it of the season and
people just don't want to bring him down
because he is got that extra gear I'm
not gonna talk myself out of the
Patriots I'll stick with my pick here
but this will be a great game I I don't
think anyone is this isn't like two
years ago or whatever it was when Marcus
Mariota went into a New England and
everyone's like they're gonna run over
them I'm not saying that I'm saying that
I'm just gonna go with Tom Brady and
Bill Belichick in January
home over the unknown of Ryan Tannehill
but it is going to be a good game and
I'm very excited for it on Saturday
night does it count as threading the
needle if the spreads five and a half
and I think the Pats are gonna win but
the Titans are gonna cover is that close
enough yeah that would be close enough
that way that would be just about close
enough I think once it gets to six I'm
gonna stop the thread the needle talk
okay well I think the Titans will cover
I got twenty three to twenty is my final
score you got a spit ball as to what you
think the scoreboard is gonna show at
the end of the game mm-hmm I feel like
it's going to be now Ryan T no III don't
know the weather I have to look at the
weather you said there's a weather storm
coming Ryan Tannehill in his ten starts
this season Mike 9 and 1/2 the over 9
and 1/2 the over so that's the dynamic
offense we're talking about they score
points they score points fast it you
know it makes you want to take the under
seeing that the Tom Brady and the way
the Patriots the DNA of this team
they're gonna try to run the ball and
keep their defense you know rested it
and make sure that they control the
clock because their offense is an
explosive but I'll take the over and
I'll take Patriots 27 Titans 21
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports